This Ryan Reynolds movie died an early death when
it hit theaters. But after years spent lying in
a cinematic grave, it's getting resurrected
for a second shot at the big time on Netflix.
While Ryan Reynolds has starred in some
well-received movies like "Deadpool," "Free
Guy," and "Waiting...," his career includes a
few box office misfires as well. Nevertheless,
his career seems relatively unshakable with
years and years as a leading man. After
appearing in several television
series and TV movies early on,
Reynolds got his first big break with
"National Lampoon's Van Wilder," in which
he plays a fast talking scamp that doesn't
play by the rules. Sounds familiar, no?
"You think Ryan Reynolds got this
far on his superior acting method?"
Possible pigeon-holing aside, Reynolds is
certainly popular these days, bolstered by
his excitement around playing Marvel's Merc
with a Mouth, his constant back and forth on
social media with his famous wife Blake Lively,
and his cell phone service company Mint Mobile.
Reynolds is a star outside of
major franchise releases too,
including in Apple TV+'s "Spirited," a Reynolds
and Will Ferrell Christmastime team-up. Now,
it seems that Reynolds' present day popularity
is breathing life into one of his older films,
and one that certainly qualified as a
flop when it was originally released.
Currently, Ryan Reynolds's "R.I.P.D." is
apparently attracting the attention of a
considerable number of viewers online,
landing it at the top of Netflix's Top
10 list. "R.I.P.D." originally
premiered in theaters back in
2013 and stars Reynolds and Jeff Bridges as
supernatural cops. Remind you of anything?
"Who're you meeting?"
"Well, it's a ship."
"A ship? I didn't see a
departure clearance for today."
R.I.P.D.'s light twist on a well-worn
genre trope is that the cops are both dead,
and now exist as phantoms in the
world of the living. Their jobs as
undead specters see them tasked with hunting
down other dead people who remain at large,
attempting to duck the afterlife. This means that
Reynolds and Bridges' characters can manifest
in the physical world in different bodies,
but with the caveat that they cannot reveal
their true nature to civilians. Of course, this
becomes a source of comedy throughout the film.
"I'm not a piece of meat put on
this earth for your gratification,
I'm a woman. Respect me or I will
castrate you like a three year old steer."
However, it seemed like the critics weren't
laughing. Despite an all-star cast comprised
of cinematic powerhouses like Reynolds, Bridges,
Kevin Bacon, and Mary-Louise Parker, critics
weren't kind to the film in reviews published
around the time of its release. Likewise,
the movie didn't perform well at the box office,
earning $79 million against a $130 million budget.
Beyond Reynolds' growing presence in
the present day pop cultural zeitgeist,
the resurrection of "R.I.P.D." as a hit on Netflix
seems to simply be the result of the film joining
the streaming service's catalog at the start of
March 2023. Nevertheless, its sudden and sharp
rise in popularity is all the more surprising when
taking into account what critics had to say about
the film in contemporaneous reviews. For example,
RogerEbert.com writer Steven Boone awarded
"R.I.P.D." one star, and concluded his review
by stating, quote, "It's an awful, awful film."
"This is a joke."
Meanwhile, for The Guardian, Mark Kermode
rated the film two-out-of-five stars,
and criticized its lack of
a proper reason to exist.
"Overall, it's a directionless
mess: too expensive for a B-movie,
too grown-up for a kids' movie (funerals,
bereavement and jokes about Steely Dan)
and too infantile for everyone else. No
wonder it died on its feet in the US."
That said, its addition to Netflix is, at
least, unsurprising. Near the end of 2022, a
prequel — with none of the original cast returning
— titled "R.I.P.D. 2: Rise of the Damned" became
available to Netflix subscribers. Of course, for
Reynolds' fanbase, quality or the existence of
a sequel may even be beside the point. Rather,
easy access to a new Reynolds film seems to have
been enough of a reason to make what was once a
major theatrical flop into a streaming success.